every time I hear somebody say Kwok I
just wanna hit them oh snap walk come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up everybody I'm stand-up
comedian hey-zeus Trejo I'm excited I'm
here in my hometown of Long Beach the
LBC I'm born and raised here my whole
upbringing is here I started comedy here
and today we're gonna eat some dank ass
tacos that just I mean they just slap
different and I'm gonna meet up with
Long Beach icon Gabriel is the big homey
first comic to put Long Beach on the map
we're gonna go check out his compound
cuz I heard he has all these cool toys
and things he's gonna show us ready
let's do it back another guy's ass it's
going down baby start the episode
already what are we doing I'm Gabriel
Iglesias welcome to my compound all
right so I rotated the tires on all your
cars clean the windshield change the oil
can we do the interview all right yes
[Music]
Gabriel glasses thank you so much for
doing this man thank you so as I'm
walking through your compound like songs
right I keep thinking like what would my
compound be and I think I'll just like
I'd have a bunch of Riegel's and Caprice
classics and pigeons I love pigeons you
take someone out the hood but you can't
take the hood out of school I love remo
you know like really yeah yeah in the
90s
speaking of which bro what's going on
here whoa please yeah is every time I've
bombed on stage oh my god yeah right it
keeps happening I don't know I made it I
bought a belt that didn't fit so I took
this and all that life
so like with any MTV Cribs episode
people want to know what's the most
expensive thing I feel like it's the
v-dub us collection here collectively
yeah it's that that would be we're
talking about just one car kind of a
toss-up between the demon and the Trans
Am both right around 200 I don't think I
was so acquainted with these up until
like a bang bus I mean it's like oh
that's a different on my shelf III
encourage everyone now to Google bang
bus you can see that it's very different
that buses stick shift this stick shift
[Music]
[Applause]
so you have a thing for v-dub buses even
to the point where you have fish tanks
yeah I got my fish tank aquariums the
guys from a TV show called tank on the
Discovery Channel
yeah they reached out and they said hey
man we'd like to do some tanks for you
are you interested in I'm like well well
how much is it gonna cost me in their
life
Ferrari what yeah so they uh they and I
made it so that it's you know doesn't
move but it'd mean here
[Music]
so you have a couple of shrines here
dedicated to wrestling and superheroes a
wrestling and superheroes kind of one of
the same Jericho's been here really yes
what did that like to be friends with
your childhood heroes like like
wrestling's cuz you you hang with
wrestles all the time it's pretty cool
especially when the personality that
you're talking to is really the
personality that's on TV like for
example stone cold is he's really stone
cold that's he doesn't turn into like
Chad you know like hi I'm Chad and all
of a sudden gets on the record god damn
at our page upside ahead knock that's
him 24/7 and no disrespect to Chad's out
there love you Chad's we love you Chad
[Music]
alright so let's do what we came here to
do let's go grab some tacos yeah I'm
done I've been waiting you moved you
wanted to look at cars I know look at
leas could look at the marvel the fish
tanks I'm a big house man you know some
betta cheese burritos I was tired no
beans no beans I'm allergic
that's crazy yeah Mexican allergic to
beans go figure that there's a bad joke
in there somewhere
oh I bet on the early on I'll do
something but I have to ask can we take
one of these buses I'll do I already got
one outside really yeah let's do it
let's go grab some tacos
Hong Kong
I am coming up on my old Mountain
neighborhood up here your old hood for
your Bebo's I mean chickens are alive
that girl does not bear mine matter of
fact you know I know we're going right
here to the right but it's literally the
next block over let's take you to mine
where it grew up okay
oh I love this yeah this place is was
always so gnarly
this boy little bit market in the corner
he's right a video store yes
the Kingston uniform aims to get porno
tape from there I don't think that'll
mask the other side but yes sir well why
not when my mom and I first moved here
it's a long beach we lived right here at
1444 and it's for rent right now yeah as
it should be first and only time I got
into a fight was right here well I got
in a fight I'm happy to tell you I am
one and oh nice I am one in Ghana
I've got him by the arm I freakin I we
said got him like a wrestler freakin saw
him around he hit the floor I jumped on
top of um that was your foreo kill kill
kill key that's how you remember okay
okay okay we're here you might want to
have your guys take that take the GoPros
out while we're in there yeah unless you
want someone take them up
[Music]
oh snap it's about to go down
alright dude I need to hang out with you
more because I hang out with you they
label the label the food I don't have to
bite into something I don't like right
yeah look at that yeah they live with
you oh yeah here we are
taco locals number three we have a nice
great spread we have a story we have
butcher you better tell them abou cheese
man cuz that's Buchi right here right in
this area the esophagus esophagus people
are looking at me like this yeah you say
that sounds like fear factor food we
have some quesadillas and then your
favorite of bean and cheese burrito with
sour cream like a genuine alright dude
well okay I'm not gonna make you hold
out anymore look at this let's dive in
cheese quesadilla
cheers Cheers oh yeah oh yeah this is
like the appetizer this is the original
Mexican appetizer right here right
before you get things started you know
when people ask me what is your favorite
food we favorite thing to eat in life
yeah cheese queso yeah very simple Wow
the amazing thing about the tacos here
is they make the handmade tortillas here
it's just it's different it slaps
different you know not not those out of
the bag no these are not out of the bag
this is some little old lady showed up
here 4 a.m. roll the dough come on come
on a penis I grew up coming to spots
like this name this spot a particular
you know like like look over here that's
not the original back in the day that
was that was our Nintendo that was our
Sega that was our our Xbox what do you
think in your opinion kind of like makes
it like a good taco spot first things
first the artwork look at horror of all
the murals on the wall right there in
the corner that's how my mom and my dad
haha what the line I mom that's how my
mom got my dad she said you look you
look horny get it you look hot and she
got on with the lasso her and then this
is a typical Mexican house that we all
wanted to get we all wanted that house
we didn't care there was pink what about
that a house appeals to our culture you
the fountain
Mexicans love fountains what is it we
love fountains will have fountains that
you put money in we love fountain drinks
soon as I got my house yeah first thing
I wanted us I want a big pot in the
front it's very cool and the guy goes no
one else in the neighborhood has a
fountain in front of their house it's
gonna look weird like that's their fault
they don't want a ball right
[Music]
so this is like a big staple in our
community here at sokolova this is not
like a foodie [ __ ] spot where people
are lined up out the door if you see a
crowd I here's cuz [ __ ] went down
there's a fight or some [ __ ] why do you
think foodies don't come to the spots
like this like safety safety hey I'm
gonna get their ass lit up what happened
I had great talk as well man
somebody stole my car and that's not a
good restaurant - if you're willing to
sacrifice the car like you know Rhino
it's 50/50 when you leave that car it
might not be there but that's how good
the food is that you're willing to risk
it and then you'll buy your order and
you're hitting the button to make sure
you still get okay or just let people
know that I have them yeah get me to
tell him you come up here as a kid you'd
ride your bike you eat here and then you
play pool next door yeah so I used to
ride my bike here and this was a deal my
dad was a gardener I used to work with
him Fridays and Saturdays well you know
how most kids would get excited when
they'd get taken out of school early I
can't get to go home I hated it I'm like
I'm gonna work cuz you know what it
meant I knew what it meant but the deal
was that I can come here they used to
have the out bus Thor top right out
front we stopped by and I couldn't order
as many as I could eat and I would like
swing for the fences and that was like
my big reward I go home shower but this
place was like a big part of my
upbringing
I always say when you think of Long
Beach to people come to mind it's Snoop
Dogg who put Long Beach on the map for
for music and you and the comedy where
you put Long Beach on the map I love
this town
this has always been home to me I mean I
was born in San Diego people think I'm
from El Paso they think I'm Hawaiian
they think I'm from Chicago I moved out
for a couple years just to see what it
was like came right back you and Snooper
are our friends I take it right if I see
snoop we say hi we were hanging out all
the time I don't want to be like yeah
that Super Bowl we're all together time
you guys I don't know I don't want to be
phony about it I mean we're cool he had
me on his show and because of him I'm
missing a whole day from my life I have
no recollection of all because what he
smokes is what he smoked
I called his weed snoops weed is a men
in black weed okay
remember the movie when black with a
little pain yeah are they friendly you
just you like that and they can program
you yeah that's what his weed does to
you Wow one of the things I've really
respect to about you coming up as a
comic and at this great place where your
and your career is that you know you
never forgot your roots you know and you
didn't have to drive anything down like
you never shied away from who you were
as a mexican-american but when people
regard you it's not a Latino comic it's
a comic it's like by being funny and
being a comic and not being kind of
pigeon-holed was that tough for you
coming up always still you know it's
still thing really people are they
always want to put a label on you right
but I think at the end of the day I'm
I'm at a point now where I you know I
got to prove it more to myself than
anything and I cherish it you know that
stage is I've given up and sacrificed
everything I've sacrificed relationships
of health free time privacy I mean you
name it it's all been given up for the
sake of that stage
yeah the dream is a is an expensive one
and people don't really know what that
price tagging tells you know
[Music]
what advice would you have for you know
standing out in the comedy world it's
not always what you say it's what you
don't that's why in my show I don't talk
about politics because you immediately
divide the audience I don't talk about
religion because people are very
sensitive about that so leave it out I
don't talk about sports because Raider
fans are [ __ ] he gotta be here
you know if you know you know do I have
an opinion absolutely I tell people you
want to hear it bum you're shot by me
five I don't hear some [ __ ] very
political in a non-political manner no
none play just want to say thank you so
much for your time dude you fed me bro I
owe ya I can't believe he did the show
up like Mac I can't believe I got to
kiss I love you yeah no this is great I
thank you for the inspiration and thank
you for everything you do man thank you
bro yes sir
smell your finger now here you go look
at that cheese and cheese a little bit
of a chopper
[Music]
darkus upon total that's tackled with
everything if you don't speak Spanish
Google last year people by grata kugel
or chop back positions good
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter tacos tacos
bro hey Suz Trejo is in the building
tacos con todo a new show on first we
feast Tuesdays at 11 a.m. this is the
initiation a last dab taco oh yeah hey
Suz Trejo
welcome to the family mom thanks ma'am
this is gonna hurt tomorrow